I'll turn to this video playing cruising
crimson from the Netherlands right yep I
want to do something different going for
what I'd been only for a change they all
play this the same iron check it's
obviously dangerous they forgot queen h4
again which seems to be helpful as I
recently learned yeah that's probably
not a good position already someone
played h3 em against me and I really
didn't know what to do with my bishop
and not sure how good it really is but
this some a four line against them
modern men only is a real problem if you
don't know to know the theoretical
details
yeah I know night night to before was
what dr. none played against Kasparov
and he got totally clobbered but then I
really don't know what to do here so he
goes to see form
just trying to stop me five for the
moment and yeah I know where that
doesn't look too great but I don't know
what to do yeah at least it's two
bishops but he can't play a five maybe
after the trade but then Bishop f5 yes
so e52 sugar fire that that's not not
clear at all they don't know if this is
so great if he's not shaking I mean he
can move the bishop again somewhere I'm
not I'm not totally sure what Bishop b5
anyway I am ok so here I can play b5
takes yeah like to take with the night
it's not possible
can I do this maybe you cannot so easily
a check it i have 93 I mean like a queen
e to F 93 and yes but 93 isn't this
somewhat dangerous at this or is six or
what exactly ok I'm going there move
first think later is six maybe no it's
not doing that I can do b5 now takes
Queen takes but then Bishop e3 is a
problem so I'm going to take ok I see if
it goes for this typical attacking
scheme but not sure this is one of the
cases where it applies I can play yeah
the rook the rook and runs into d6 you
know what do I go here it's not too
great to retreat it but i will i will
take this take this bishop i will take
this bishop maybe I should have done
that anyway I wasn't before him I
couldn't have taken it but without the
lid if the bishop is gone I mean at
least I can I can yeah let's let's take
this thing night a for I have a form
I am but that's not that's not so bad v
5m takes Knight takes with tempo or
queen takes with the temple Queen takes
Bishop e3 may have night takes a cesium
yeah come on this rook is not well
placed should a six it's not really
doing much maybe just this one I'm
checking this rook forcing it to think
to see five okay take that could have
taken f5 this is this was stronger very
very possible but still I don't think
that this is so great for me how much
policies do I have just one pawn okay
it's just one pawn
Queen f6 maybe take say I can play 95 at
the end yeah probably still 97 check is
not the end of the world
for Queenie one if he allows it so this
is an exchange yeah a complete exchange
okay it's jack let's get get Queens
traded the night on the seven is really
i mean important is an understatement
could never be six through p7 p8 just I
want to speak to pawn already
yeah maybe I mean the seven is nice but
these three is even better or you fall
for a fork
I am he's got seven seconds so it really
should be enough even timewise white
forfeits on time poor yellow I mean I
want to just wanted to do something else
but they really play this is this line
of then the therefore I b5 line I think
that blackjack probably do something
like that flick in this check at least
this makes it a little bit more
difficult to play age three and so that
Bishop g4 as possible but I don't know
at all how this is played I mean this
was probably not not anything anything
too great yeah I mean after c4 I believe
I'm pretty ok I get the night to d3 and
this Bishop on a force misplaced I'm not
sure about this Bishop v5 idea this
looks it looks a bit um a bit out of
place maybe in this sir and destruction
champion probably okay of course yeah
sometimes the computer just takes this
and wins with F with e for coming that's
a very simple solution he really is just
a couple of points down for no
compensation yeah okay well the Benoni
what can you do okay thanks for watching